my mama
meet Winnie wangoi a polti farmer from
juja in kiambu County one of the urban
and Perry urban areas in Kenya where
poultry farming is growing rapidly
Winnie is one of 50 pilot Farmers
involved in the practice and behavior
study by the food and agriculture
organization a few under the Africa's
sustainable livestock 2050 funded by the
usaid I met foul like three years ago
and I have gone to their seminars
several of them many in Nairobi and
others in machakos and the Really insist
on proper practices on preparing of my
chicken up to the time I take them to
the market this project
called an Africa sustainable livestock
are trying to safeguard Public Health
about emerging infectious diseases and
some of these diseases are coming from
livestock and into humans from the study
it was noted that stakeholders tend more
to adopt practices that are anticipated
to have a positive impact on their
business such as vaccination
change this a checklist was developed
jointly with County and National
veterinary services with priority
biosecurity practices that could lead to
the reduction of emerging zoonotic
diseases such as salmonella and to
mitigate antimicrobial resistance that
checklist formed our basis of
sensitizing and training all the actors
foreign
area and the dirty area but after
training tuna separated the
feelings and the capacities
separately
certificate at least
with our training there's been reduced
mortalities within their throats the
banks also gain the slaughter weight
faster
and this gives them good money although
they lose governing the poultry value
chain business in Kenya there exists
notable gaps but the ammunition has not
been very good in the future
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you